sandra oh had a major fangirl moment as  she teamed up with james corden and  duran duran for an epic collaboration  yeah in a sneak peek of carpool karaoke  the series season five sandra could  hardly keep it together as she joined  simon lebon and john taylor to jam out  to some of their classic hits like girls  on film and rio take it away sandra  we'll see ya  [Applause]  oh my god  two minutes later  [Music]  this is so fun i mean i had pictures of  you on my walls  killing eve it's one of the best series  i've ever seen thank you  anyway i just my god i i'm such a i i  can't even i i it's okay  [Music]  is it possible that we could perform on  stage together  [Applause]  [Music]  maybe there's like one more i mean like  i just i need to keep this fantasy going